[Música]
fala sobre compras pois é fácil toda a
gente faz compras
eu queria dizer que nós aqui nesta sala
fazemos compras todos os dias fazemos
como as contas anunciou está marcado
quando alguém faz anos e precisamos de
ir comprar presentes quando vamos
comprar o pão profissional nós em todos
os momentos nós estamos a fazer compras
claro que algumas compras são gravadas
pensamos falamos sobre elas e algumas
completamente automáticas
na verdade só nos parecem automáticas
porque na nossa cabeça existe todo um
sistema complexo nos ajuda a tomar as
melhores decisões
isso porque as nossas necessidades são
cada vez mais sofisticados porque nós
nós somos especiais
nós precisamos de produtos à nossa
medida a noiva das nossas ambições das
nossas necessidades
isso acontece com todos os produtos
mesmo ativos possam parecer mais comuns
como um guardanapo de papel
se eu pedir o meu filho para ele comprar
um guardanapo de papel eu vai ter que
responder em essas perguntas feitas por
outros maiores outros mais pequenos da
nan os governantes são os grandes até os
pequenininhos uso do couro vai ser gorda
na pe e ainda nem sequer começamos a
falar das marcas porque nós também vamos
seguir qual é marca do guaraná tucano
for na nossa mesa e portanto como é que
nós conseguimos efetivamente tomar estas
decisões assim tão rápido quando estamos
à frente do nape um terreno que é um
professor da london business school vem
nos dizer que nós agrupamos as
características dos produtos em duas
grandes festas numa sexta colocando
aquelas a que chamam horda qualifyer são
os qualificadores dos mínimos olímpicos
são as características que os produtos
têm que ter para serem consideradas por
nós quando nós temos as crianças mas
depois há outro grupo outra cesta são
jorge o inox são aquelas categorias
aquelas características do
os artigos que nos fazem ser vencedores
faça todos os outros é que é o que nós
vamos escolher as marcas também vão ser
vistas por nós dessa maneira também vão
ser uma das características que nós
vamos olhar quando escolhemos um produto
e claro é a importância da marca tem
importância tem importância que nós
queremos dar em função do produto já é
um produto importante para nós e da
relevância que a própria marca já tem na
nossa vida nós na verdade fizemos vamos
comprar um telemóvel ou dizemos que
vamos comprar um iphone o que fomos na
nossa lista de espera o mercado o nome
do arquivo o nome da marca é isso mesmo
claro que as marcas querem ser isso
mesmo querem ter a capacidade de ser um
dos critérios que vai influenciar a
nossa compra a nossa escolha
mas para isso tem que passar pelo
primeiro teste o texto dá confiança tem
que ganhar a confiança do seu público
alvo
mas então que estudou confiar
confira uma coisa relativamente sinto
véu eu confio e ou qualquer coisa alguém
espero não perder nada com isso nada com
essa troca espera um equilíbrio e quando
fazemos compras antes mesmo do dinheiro
ao ganha em troca quer um produto ter um
serviço e varanda quando nós não
confiamos quando achamos que este
negócio pode não ser assim tão
equilibrado
o que fazemos é por um prêmio temos com
seguro
jones fez isso mesmo ela transou com
marca d'água elas grosso pois um prêmio
no acordo pré-nupcial 5 milhões de
dólares que as forças traída por michael
douglas e este foi o valor é quem está
dando certo nos jogos viu a sua
confiança estão os assuntos são muito
muito muito complicado
vamos passar às crianças que são bem
mais tempo às crianças com filtro
natureza as crianças confiam nos animais
que os animais nos vão fazer mal
confiam nos produtos de referência nos
pais nos avós nos irmãos confiam no pam
da onu os cariocas no rato mickey e
portanto quando um destes amigos lhes
apresenta um produto seu gato me que
gosta destas lojas
eu gosto do rato mickey provavelmente eu
também gosta relaxa é isto o efeito das
mascotes e é óbvio que as marcas
conhecem as infantis e criam as suas
fotos ou propriedades e outras que já
existem para serem promotores dos seus
produtos
é natural que assim seja estão é que as
crianças acreditam e acreditam na
publicidade
antes dos 10 anos das crianças ainda não
têm o ceticismo todo para desconfiar e
portanto vão acreditar e stan e esta
questão de acreditar na publicidade que
vem vai acompanhar os trantornos a vida
vai influenciar seu comportamento de
compra e não quando são crianças e tem
que influenciar os seus países mas
depois também mais tarde
acho tudo muito interessante sobre isso
sobre cereais em que basicamente
colocaram adultos escolher duas marcas
seriais qual é a marca mais saudável e
se todos conheciam as duas marcas mas
numa das marcas tenham visto publicidade
quando eram crianças
antes dos 10 anos e no outro caso só
tenham visto essa publicidade mais tarde
já em adultos e o que acontece é que
estes assuntos
iam ficar todos enviesadas por aquilo
que viram nem criança escolheram sempre
sempre a marca da qual vieram
publicidade quando eram mais novos pois
nós vamos crescendo e nosso ceticismo
aumenta muito
dentro da sala mas tantas lembrar pais
tranquilizou docentes passam por aquela
questão da vias em que confiam em si
próprios e só eles é que sabem tudo em
outras alturas não confiam em si não
confiam quase ninguém mas confiam nos
seus padres e confiam na sua rua no seu
ídolo na sua frente ã tanto que eles vão
fazer é imitar comportamento vão querer
evitar todos os comportamentos de compra
que possam ali é só isso que justifica a
relação que eu vou sentar em com bebidas
alcoólicas e tabaco não é primeira opção
e não cheira mal sai mal e ainda assim o
centro vai se dar bem estar e isso vai
acontecer com elas
nós vamos esquecendo obviamente já em
adultos
ainda assim alguma pressão dos pares
relativamente às nossas escolhas nós
nesta altura
criamos ser aquilo que fez a escolha
melhor porque somos os mais em 200 e
portanto vamos reunir provas vamos unir
tudo o que estiver a nosso alcance para
mostrar que não só a decisão é melhor
vamos perguntar isso para os outros
graças a deus vamos ficando mais maduros
e mais livros daquilo que os outros
pensam sobre nós e quando chegamos a
esta altura da nossa vida o que queremos
saber mesmo é nossa vivência quais foram
as nossas experiências de marcas é que
nos acompanharam durante toda a vida e
nunca nos deixaram ficar mal cobrar a
pena arriscar
será que tudo isso é importante porque
quando estamos a gerir uma marca estamos
a gerir uma marca que se dirige a um
determinado público e portanto temos que
ver como é que as público em particular
se relaciona e cria relações de
confiança com a nossa marca a partir de
simples confiar significa também
consistência e se nós não falhar mãos
enquanto marta não vamos ter problemas
vamos com conferir a confiança só não é
assim tão simples
o mundo é muito mais complicado que isso
desde logo porque existem pessoas
existem pessoas à frente e atrás da
marca e portanto a marca vai falhar vai
falhar por trás da marca existem pessoas
e ficaram humano e quem está a gerir a
vaga nessas vezes vai falhar a marca vai
falhar porque a sua frente estão pessoas
e as pessoas como eu diria no início são
cada vez mais diferentes têm
necessidades diferentes eo para
conseguir enquanto marca contribuído
para a pessoa a vou falhar com absorver
muitas das vezes é isso que vai
acontecer então não usava o que as
marcas precisam é algo diferente do que
as marcas precisam e de criar algo maior
do que uma relação de confiança
precisam de ter uma relação em
condicional precisam ter a certeza que
as pessoas vão perdoar quando as coisas
correm mal não vão querer feche vão
querer médios apaixonados que lutem por
ela que gritem por ela em cada momento e
há marcas fazem isto mesmo que nos fazem
gritar por elas eu vou fazer aqui um
pequeno exercício convosco para perceber
quem acredita nas suas marcas possam
lançar uma marca da champs toda a gente
lava a cabeça vamos partir desse
princípio e portanto eu acredito que
vocês saibam qual é marca do vosso
champô e portanto eu vou fazer uma
contagem de 60 empresas e vocês vão
poder gritar pela vossa marca de xampu
em 32 o 1
a miséria
vocês não têm nenhuma relação de amor
com a nossa marca de xampu
vocês são capazes de trair voz chamou a
qualquer momento
como é possível que chora com isso não
pode ser bom vou procurar outro exemplo
é um exemplo que seja mais profundo algo
que eu tenho certeza que vocês não usam
possam trocar tudo na vossa vida mas que
essa marca não usam eu vou contar até
três e vocês vão gritar eu gosto do
futebol em 3 2 1
[Aplausos]
isto meus caros e amor pela marca é
arriscar pela marca e ficamos a saber de
sonhos um champô e ser um clube de
futebol
[Risadas]
este é o menor valor a minha filha e nós
resolvemos levá lo avisa aí quando ela
tinha quatro anos porque é a magia da
disney ela nem na nossa das princesas
a princesa favorita ela era a bela de a
bela eo monstro então nós fomos nós que
o menor para a disney em três dias na
lista ela não apareceu em nenhum desfilo
nenhum tragédia franciscana claro de
salinor menor tabela ela está doente
ela não produzir nessas três dias mas um
dia os papais vão ganhar mais dinheiro e
vão trazer novamente a disney e vai ver
ela o que vamos fazer nada né
nove meninas que vestido dela hoje
pensei bom espetacular a gente vem pra
que gastar dinheiro na gema não sei que
é e amigos ponto desta maneira não há
direito não há nenhuma mãe como essa
isso um pai como essa isso não é
desculpa
isabela ano foi uma novela é novela era
uma relação de amor e portanto pessoa a
ela as marcas vão falhar vão falhar a
falha de muitas coisas
o impacto do erro mas também a nossa
personalidade enquanto marca enquanto
marca
temos à nossa frente uma das histórias
que mais gosta é esta
isto é um pepino ea linha preta é uma
minhoca e esta foi a fotografia que um
cliente da testa até um supermercado na
inglaterra
gostou não foi sul da pesca uma falha
enorme da texto venha acompanhada pelas
seguintes a mensagem eo caminho é longo
e vou fazer uma tradução simultânea
ontem fui a lógica maravilhoso
adoro quando me encontrei uma minhoca e
pensei olha vou ganhar um novo animal de
estimação e então chamei as minhas
crianças que vieram a ocorrer conhecer o
seu novo animal de estimação e
resolvemos dar nome
o heleno o elenco do órgão o lema
minhoca só com o irmão está muito parado
ou não se mexe passadas 24 horas eu
conseguiria continua sem se mexer e não
só treinaremos às tantas o rei morreu
talvez tenha sido o plástico estava
demasiado apertado e agora testa como
vai resolver
eu tenho três crianças chateada e eu
tenho que planear o funeral do helena e
perdi todo o meu amor por sanduíches
tupi no bom comer texto responde a isto
até que eu podia fazer várias coisas um
pedido desculpas podia enviar um talão
com a compra do tupi não pôde enviar um
cachorro um cachorrinho para substituir
o elenco enquanto animal de estimação
o hobby do serviço australiano fez uma
coisa diferente logo respondeu dizendo
bom nos próximos dias eu vou o festival
lá mas em todo o elenco queria se tanto
a isso e portanto não vou poder ir ao
enterro do elenco mas escrevi um poema
gostava que fosse turismo no enterro do
elenco do homem escreveu ea história não
ficou por aqui porque a empresa é ver a
fotografia do enterro além do órgão em
toda a internet disse que fazia questão
de pagar as custas do enterro do elenco
do ó
foi isso que aconteceu três dias 30 mil
partilha 10 mil comentários no facebook
as marcas vão falhar as marcas toca as
pessoas nascem crescem e vão ver o mundo
fazem birras e vão falhar
tal como as pessoas e as pessoas tal
como as marcas têm nomes têm sido ligado
tem valores são vistas analisadas julgá
las por toda a gente e vão criando
relações em função do comportamento
também em função daquilo que dizem do
caixão por dizer do que fazem e deixam
por fazer em função de tudo isso criam
relações de amor criam relações de
confiança
isso vai ser fundamental para
conseguirem ultrapassar é que os
momentos em que falham na verdade é uma
deixamos marcas uns nos outros
espero deixar a minha
[Aplausos]